What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Many of you have requested us
to make a Pongfinity mobile game battle
Between the three of us
So today we will see who is the champion
And to make it a bit more exciting
Everybody will draw a random bat
Random ball
And a random map
Each of us get one try, let's see who wins!
Otto starts
Ok I will try to pick the winning combination
Let's start with the racket
A guitar.
That's not really good for my character
Otto plus guitar is a pretty slow combination
Yeah, really slow!
Balloon!
That's the worst possible!
Almost the worst possible combination so far!
Ah, Pongfinity Hall!
At least that's a nice hall!
I'd be very surprised if Otto wins with that combination!
It was guitar...
Balloon...
And Pongfinity Hall is there already
And also everybody gets a Safety Net
Good luck Otto!
You have a winning combination
No I don't - this is one of the worst combinations in the whole game.
So the Safety Net means that if you miss
the Safety Net will save you one time.
You should take the power-up
I used my Safety Net there
Was that a tactical use of the Safety Net?
No it wasn't.
Well now you can see
You got the Eye [power-up].
Easily over 50!
Yeah
You got it but then you missed!
Exactly 50!
I tried an around the net but missed it
Stupid game - I miss an around the net!
But you said that you will get 50
Yeah, I was hoping to get 50
and I was happy with that so I just stopped it
That's quite a good score!
Okay, let's see what combination I will get.
Choose your weapon first
A phone!
I wouldn't say that's the best choice!
I don't think it has a very good reach
No, it doesn't
Basketball!
Phone and basketball!
Interesting combination!
I wonder if anybody has ever played with these combinations voluntarily...
Forest!
That's a nice place!
Agility - phone has a quite good agility
Your agility is super good
because my character is quite fast and the phone has a good agility
Let's go!
I think I will at least beat Miikka!
A few warm-up rounds
You know the character gotta stay warm
Yeah, Miikka always needs to warm up first
Good luck!
WHAT!?
Look at how slow it is!
That's pretty slow!
The Dash [move] is that slow!
How is it that slow!?
This is terrible
Well at least I have time to think!
Oh no...
That was a mistake!
I know where its gonna hit it
You're not going to get 20 there
Well you have the Safety Net still
I'll get that diamond!
Why did I get the diamond!?
That was the classical rookie mistake - to get the diamond.
Wider table [power-up]
18!
Good score Miikka!
Way to go!
At least I get a free gift
Ooh, a lot of coins!
Are you feeling lucky Emil?
I'm not feeling particularly lucky
but I think I can be luckier than you guys
I'm sure I'll get the 5-star racket - the best one.
4-star racket!
Alrightey!
Okay, the ball.
Beach ball!
That's not the best one - that's quite slow.
Alright, the beach would be suitable for the beach ball but we'll see...
No way!
It's the beach!
We didn't even plan this!
Alright, let's go!
Yeah, that goes so fast
A bit faster than for Miikka
with the phone and the basketball
Even if you get like a score of 100
it would take the same time as my 18...
Pretty much yeah
I think we are going to be here for a while
Yup.
Hopefully, yes!
Okay, 4 more!
Don't miss this one!
The winner!
But let's see how far I can go
Can I get to the robot?
Ooh, you're battery is dying!
Quickly Emil!
No!
What?
[Screen recording ended because of the 15% notification]
Nooo!
That was unlucky
Hope you enjoyed this Pongfinity Game battle
and hope you enjoyed seeing me win for once!
Thank you Otto!
If you haven't got the app yet
You can download it
It's free on both Apple and Android
And if you want to give yourself a challenge
Go and beat Emil's high score
It's still the world record
428!
That's the score to beat for you!
Otto whispering: "Emil's the best"
Until next time!